[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pippa clara and harry cole welcome to
both of you on what is another very busy
night once again so to the front pages
then let us start with the guardian it
says boris johnson has prompted fresh
outrage as allegations have now emerged
that a birthday party was held for him
at downey street during lockdown in june
of 2020.
that's also the lead story for the times
johnson held lockdown birthday party at
number 10 their headline
the eye describes the prime minister's
problems as growing
oh what a surprise the star is not
impressed by the latest allegations of
lockdown breaking parties in downing
street
the sun tells the prime minister you
can't have your cake and eat it boris
former brexit negotiator lord frost says
the planned rise in national insurance
must be scrapped in order to help the
economy that's the lead story for the
mail
u.s president joe biden is preparing to
send thousands of soldiers to eastern
europe in the event of a russian
invasion of ukraine reports the
telegraph
according to the financial times nato
member states have begun sending fighter
jets and ships to parts of eastern
europe in case conflict in ukraine
escalates quickly
the express leading on the prime
minister's words of warning to the
russian president vladimir putin that
any invasion would be painful and bloody
and the metro has the headline nato jets
ready to scramble
just a quick reminder too that by
scanning the qr code that you'll see on
your screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and uh
hear what our guests have to say so
let's bring in pepakura and harry cole
two big stories there uh nato and uh
ukraine and russia national insurance
too but uh dominating for a number of
newspapers once again events that down
the street including your paper the sun
harry
yeah i mean there's obviously a massive
uh growing international crisis um
on the ukraine border boris johnson
tonight um speaking to world leaders
including biden including the heads of
nato the heads of the eu uh yet back at
home has been dragged into yet another
allegation about partygate now this time
last week uh there was almost a sort of
tinderbox feeling uh in downing street
that was slightly uh sorry in in in
westminster that was slightly
abated by the defection of a victorian
peter labor uh which seemed to actually
calm the mood down but there was a
feeling from a lot of tory critics that
actually one more big revelation and it
might just push
um
those letters those crucial letters for
calling for a leadership calling for a
vote of confidence in the prime minister
over the threshold of 54. so we'll have
to wait and see tomorrow what happens
there now number 10 are pushing back
quite hard they're saying look this is
uh you know the prime minister was just
out of hospital he was his staff
gathered to say happy birthday he was
there for 10 minutes a little bit harder
to explain why his interior designer was
one of those guests when at this exact
same time police were trolling around
the country giving fines to people who
have birthday parties saying these are
not exempt so
it was remains to be seen quite how much
that anger will build up again uh in the
run-up to the sue gray report later
expected later this week but
it seems to be the scandal the prime
minister just can't seem to move on from
yes indeed and in terms of the interior
designer
she was present in downing street on the
19th of june working on the
refurbishment she was not invited uh
their statement said to any birthday
celebrations for the prime minister uh
but she was in the cabinet office
waiting to talk to him so fortuitous
timing i guess that she was there in the
uh brief less than 10 minutes that he
was um leading a number of other
newspapers the mirror i think we might
have as well if not yeah let's have a
look at that as well your paper then uh
pippa um clearly it's been a focus for
you pm's number 10 birthday bash in
lockdown and that is a photograph is it
not of an official visit he made to a
school that day in hertfordshire where
school children in the school had
presented him with that birthday cake
and uh sung to him in fact um how
serious do you see these allegations
because there's twin events aren't there
um one in the cabinet office this
surprise you know birthday do arranged
by his wife so the allegation goes from
itv news and then a later
event uh which which stanley says was
outside and not in the flat
yes so the first
alleged gathering in the in the cabinet
room itself about 30 people
his wife carrie leading a rendition
amongst staff of uh happy birthday as
she and apparently the designer lulu
little presented a birthday cake um
number 10 hasn't denied this was a party
which is quite interesting another
another shift another iteration in their
response to these many allegations of of
lockdown busting gatherings
and um
they are not don't appear tonight to be
trying to justify to some sort of work
event that the prime minister just
popped into there's no real claim of
that and anyway even if it was a work
event why were his wife and interior
designer there um so it sounds as if and
we're also told that um
or i understand that uh sue gray was
already aware of this gathering so it's
not likely to delay her
her report findings
um any any longer than it already than
these
new allegations already had done
um but
almost the most serious suggestion which
is denied by number 10 is that the party
then moved upstairs and there was a
gathering
of the prime minister's family
um
potentially his siblings his friends i
don't know who i don't know who's on
that guest list but inside the number 10
flat and of course that is more serious
because it's at a time when um social
gatherings were banned indoors and
there was no excuse for people that
weren't
members of the number 10 staff
to be in downing street the the other
gathering the birthday gathering
downstairs all the staff were working
there number 10 are trying to downplay
its significance tonight sending out
ministers suggesting that the pm just
popped in
downing street is saying that that so
the gathering later in the evening
actually took place in the garden um
but you know sources from from a variety
of media organizations now tonight to
say that's not the case it was upstairs
and of course this isn't the first time
that they've been allegations about
gatherings in the number 10 parties in
the number 10 flat there was more at the
weekend naming two of carrie simmons
carrie johnson's
friends who worked at the time in the
cabin office and not in number 10 again
they claimed that it was a work a work
event that they were there for and going
way back to the end of november that
very first story that we ran at the
mirror about a couple of these
these get-togethers also quoted sources
suggesting that there had been parties
in the flat as well again number two
number 10 i'm mrs johnson's
spokesman but you know there are so many
allegations now that if you almost feel
overwhelmed by them and you know sue
grey certainly had a lot got her work
cut out trying to establish the facts on
all of these these many get-togethers
yes and just on the cabinet room one the
afternoon one just after 2 p.m a group
of staff danny street said working
number 10 that day gathered briefly in
the cabinet room after a meeting to wish
pm a happy birthday he was there for
less than 10 minutes so stressing the
work element of it still actually for
for that one the eye johnson's problems
grow with birthday league party as the
eyes front page
uh the guardian as well again with that
picture
um from 19th of june 2020 johnson faces
fresh outrage over birthday party in
number 10. um
we've got another one let me see let's
see the star
should we be surprised bozo had a how'd
you pronounce it how'd you pronounce
bozo sorry bozo had a big birthday bash
with 30 jumps well the rest of us were
all in lockdown oh what a surprise
so my question is after while we wait
for sue gray is whatever she finds we
need to interpret that they did treat
themselves differently don't we harry
that all these events they had they they
didn't see that they were following the
same rules
yeah and in a weird way i think actually
the sort of am the hype of waiting for
sue gray is we've uh as you know
launched a million memes online and even
some online poetry about the wait for
sue gray and this report is i think a
larger a huge amount of expectations
being put on this report that actually
by all intents by all accounts won't be
not least its own remit won't be making
a judgment on this now the mood i get
actually from the people that really
want to knife boris johnson and want to
get rid of him is that you know
it doesn't really it doesn't really
matter the way to pursue grey they're
going to find a way to
to to keep on punching that bruise we've
seen in the last five days uh from the
brexiteer
right we've seen these allegations of
blackmail and bullying by party whips um
then yesterday on sunday on sunday we
saw a you know sort of shocking
allegations from mr ghani another member
of the sort of powerful 1922 committee
who was sort of agitating against the
prime minister and we saw of course don
cummings again pop up today saying look
a very menacing uh social media
intervention to say tory mps look if you
want this nightmare to end you've got to
get rid of him he's saying that
there are cabinet office officials
actively working to ask the prime
minister this week so in a weird way sue
gray is almost sort of the one of many
problems on the on the horizon and
frankly the you know even boris
johnson's closest allies today have been
slightly conceding that
his enemies can smell blood there's a
momentum to it now the sort of drumbeat
of negative stories is gonna keep going
and lots of people that do not like
boris johnson are not going to rest
until they get him so sorry cabinet
office officials do they mean civil
servants or special advisers well that's
that it was it was very loosely worded
actually it said officials in downing
street and the cabinet office were
were preparing to push him off the ice
uh this week
which is quite an incendiary claim i
think on on another day would be a
remarkable claim and noticeably he has
come out today today and said that he
won't be cross-examined or interviewed
or meet face-to-face with sue gray under
the proviso of apparently he's worried
that pm will twist his words but some
skepticism tonight from some senior
tories on the record in duncan smith
tonight saying that's not a man who's
confident in his story and if he's not
willing to put it himself up for
interview then perhaps his allegations
should be treated with a bit of a bit of
a picture okay just very quickly to
pippa then if there are those who want
to keep on punching the bruise as as
harry put it it comes down to numbers
now doesn't it and and this is what we
don't yet know and that's why the sugray
report might be critical in in tipping
that that crucial number over the edge
yes you need 54 letters to be put into
starting a confidence fade
and a confidence process and last week
it looked like they were getting there
but then of course kristen wakeford
pulled back uh it defected it and the
rebels then 2019
intake pulled back from the brink uh
nobody knows how many letters have
really gone in but certainly the
entities that i speak to most of them
seem to suggest those that are
considering it are waiting for students
report to come not least because they
think it will give lots of cover and
possibly even further down the line they
want to see how the spring pans out um
with the cost of living crisis and onto
the may elections they're very conscious
that this is somebody that they
supported in boris johnson he was a
great electoral asset to the
conservative party multiple election
winner and they feel that if that
election asset turns into an election
electoral liability at the may elections
then they've got a valid reason for
pushing okay and pippa apologies for
rushing you um boris johnson obviously
needs to be seen as a global statesman
right now which is the other subject
we're coming on to those tensions which
are rising on the ukrainian russia
border back with that story in just a
moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now pepakura and
harry cole welcome back to both of you
so let's go to ukraine shall we at some
high-level meetings today uh not least
in nato this big phone conversation
later on pippa uh with the u.s president
as well and european leaders
and what what have we learned what what
is what is europe and the west prepared
to do
it's astonishing really that you know
such an
event which
ordinarily would be on the front page of
every newspaper and dominating every tv
news bulletin there's so much else going
on domestically that that isn't the case
but there was this big phone call
tonight between biden and the leaders of
the european union and nato boris
johnson and other and other um world
leaders about how they were going to
address the the russian threats to
ukraine
as you'll know we've already got some
troops on the ground
um training forces and we've sent over
anti-thousands of
anti-anti-tank guns um and other uh
other countries across europe sending
sort of a variety of jets and ships and
all the rest of its neighboring
countries the big commitment is from the
states which has
said it's going to send or already sent
5000 troops to the baltic states in
lithuania latvia and estonia and it's
got 50 000 more in reserve now there's
no suggestion that any of these are
actually going to go into the ukraine
should russia um should russia across
the border but it's more about
protecting the countries on the eastern
flank and it gets this all sort of gets
the heart of the the sort of the
the crux of all of this which is that
vladimir putin ultimately
says that he's on the board of ukraine
because he's concerned about sort of the
build up of western troops and western
presence in some of these countries um
but you know by doing this effectively
the west is kind of giving him the
excuse if you like um
and making him feel emasculated and
russia feel more under threat um by
having sort of greater presence for
western thought of western troops there
harry shaking his head i'm not
justifying his actions at all but
they're in this kind of standoff
situation where you have you know this
massive threat determined to sort of
take over
the annex the crimea ready in 2014 and
um united on the brink of doing the same
with the rest of the ukraine a big
threat to its neighbors and in a really
difficult position
will use it
sorry to introduce we've got 20 seconds
left just very quickly the pm gloomy
intelligence almost trying to appeal
over um putin's head to the russian
people saying this is going to be
another chechner for you
yeah really interesting tonight is that
actually perhaps things are moving
quicker than anyone uh even even things
we've got uh james heap a defensive
minister tomorrow writing for us who is
that we are becoming aware of a
significant number of individuals who
are assessed to be associated with
russian military intelligence sorry
russian military advanced force
operations who are already located in
ukraine so i think we'll be hearing a
lot more about that tomorrow the fact
that actually perhaps this is uh really
now on the cusp of happening okay very
interesting we will talk more thank you
both very much indeed peppa harry cole
thank you for that good to see you both
and uh both of you staying with us right
through the 11 for all the very latest
on that military build up the problems
on the border with russia and ukraine
and also the allegations too of the uh
the latest uh
at downey street with the prime minister
back in